well this is actually an interesting uh
kind of like combined conversation we're
talking about 1A and 2A and I gotta I
gotta speak from vosh okay zovash is a
he's a socialist he's a leftist we've
had him on the show he responded to the
story about Jen sackey saying this seems
pretty effed he said companies have a
right to create and enforce TOs and the
government has a right to legislate but
the idea of the government informally
pressuring tech companies into changing
their TOS that legislation seems pretty
scary I'm not sure the solution to the
mass spreading of disinformation is but
some solutions certainly seem more in
1984 than others and then he made a joke
all my political opinions are formed by
feeding tweets into an algorithm which
rates them on a scale of 1776 to 1984.
until I have a stronger opinion on this
my official position is that we can fix
social media disinformation by simply
Banning everyone I don't like now what's
funny is he has a follow-up tweet
completely unrelated of his Smith and
Wesson 22 Victory which uh he says came
back after sending it off for repairs
looking very handsome in its new grip in
my honest opinion and I'm just like all
right we can agree that that was bad and
we can agree that the guns are good all
right we agree we agree yeah I wonder I
I ultimately wonder when we talk about
the potential for civil war collapse or
balkanization if there really will be a
major conflict if the major conflict
will be the left populace versus the
right populist because I kind of don't
think it will be I think it'll be more
establishment machine
industrialist yeah we were talking
earlier immune forest in the kitchen
downstairs and I was I think it's going
to be economic rather than military I
mean there might be a military behind
the economic but I think it'll be like a
shattering into State currency or
something and then Florida will be like
we're not accepting Arkansas coin if you
act like this and the FEDS like you have
to accept Arkansas coin and they're like
no no but I think
um I think the populists might end up
avoiding each other to a certain degree
the problem though is a lot of the
people on the left who are actually
particularly authoritarian but I don't
think that they're populists I think
there are left populists there are many
of them Unfortunately they give too much
power to the Democratic establishment
but I think if things actually reach you
know if if it hits the fan
I think most people who are populist or
libertarian leaning are going to be like
I'm gonna sit at my house and grow
vegetables leave me the F alone it's the
authoritarians who are going to be
cracking down and trying to go after
people can you real quick Define popular
populism it's when you are uh supported
by and working for the interests of the
population of the people popular support
then you have elitism which is when
you're working for and supported by the
powers of the elites and then you have
the establishment which is mostly the
the elite infrastructure the machines
the old money the traditional
um Power structures so Trump is a
populist he has almost no support from
the elites Tucker Carlson is an elite
gives them some support so there's some
people there for sure
but he has almost no Elite support but
he has tons of popular support the
elites can muster up a strong force
against that and restrict access to
institutions so all the institutions are
all for the most part elitist yeah so
the left populists they were the Bernie
Sanders crowd but then Bernie went
totally establishment then they started
voting in people like Biden because I
don't think they understood what they
were doing and interestingly
the right populist movement is actually
not even completely economically or
culturally right-wing but it's just
older left-wing people like you know
like I used to be or you probably were
at some point or still it definitely was
yeah more leftists and now it's kind of
like hey freedom is important and what
the establishment is doing is wrong Ben
you have these younger left populists
who just
The Establishment is better because
Trump is a fascist I don't know better
authoritarian populist
where they're like we're gonna legislate
for everyone to make it better for
everyone and then they end up ruining it
for a bunch of people on accident I
think this is a really good place to put
a line of demarcation or a
differentiation between two concepts
because when you're talking about
populism we describe somebody as a
populist I don't prescribe them as a
populist I describe Donald Trump as a
populist because he gets his support
from people a person doesn't become a
populist in the sense of it's a thing
that they become it's a method of
description right and so whereas in the
same thing in that elitist thing is like
well you could also say that some people
are just they prefer to work for the
good of the elites so I think populism
growing is different than democracy in
the sense it's not a system of
governance
but the issue with populism versus
authoritarianism
where we're starting to see this kind of
Terror itself apart is the
authoritarianism is a top-down approach
whereas the populism is a bottom-up
approach from of cultural norms yes
right so they so gen saki overtly States
we are an authoritarian we have an
authoritarian view on cultural norms we
have the right as the elites to dictate
to you what is okay and not okay whereas
Donald Trump in that if he's being
described as a populist
um is in more of a symbiotic
relationship of saying I under you have
the values are coming from the people
and they put their position into Donald
Trump I will say when it comes to this
tweet from vosh about the Smith Wesson
22 Victory is uh my biggest criticism is
that he chose the victory because I have
one and it and it and it fails to eject
the the case like it just keeps jamming
and so I went online and they were like
you got to like file down the what's it
called the ejector pin or whatever yeah
it might be the ejector yeah and so I'm
like you know you shoot a couple times
it gets down vosh man there's there's
better 22s I'm just kidding it's
actually a great cook it's great yeah I
mean and also 22 especially 22 handguns
are notorious for being picky with
ammunition right right I was kidding I
was kidding your gun looks pretty cool
but we do need more Tim and Vost drama
yeah we do well well we're we're uh the
plan right now is Charlie Kirk and vosh
on August 3rd cool thing I like about
vosh and his name's Ian I want to call
Ian what's up dude is he's like really
smart like it's whatever your political
beliefs are and this is kind of what I I
always want to remind myself of other
people about it doesn't really matter
what your political beliefs are if
you're really smart and open-minded and
you want to and you like listening to
people go for it you have to have your
discussion and your ideas you don't
gotta you don't gotta like the guy you
got to beat him in a debate of course so
for for anybody who's saying they think
he's dumb or they don't like him it's
like yeah well definitely not then if
you know it if you know it you can beat
them in debate there you go that's what
it's all about uh anybody who's willing
to come in here and sit down and have
that debate that's that's great I
respect that because there's a lot of
people who are grifting who outright
refuse to come in they're they're even
people who are not even like they're
people who are moderately right who are
scared of talking about certain things
so somebody wants to come and sit in the
lines then and have that I mean look
he's agreed to sit here with Charlie and
me Charlie Me and Charlie don't agree on
everything but we definitely don't agree
with vosh so he's like willing to sit
down on what's what's effectively a two
against one debate all right that's he's
great about debating I like that about
him yeah I think I think we're seeing a
shift in the way that we talk about
things like especially like intelligence
is that there's a difference between
being intelligent and being an honest
intellectual
so somebody likes again you could take
somebody who has the hardware and board
the practice and there they understand
something very thoroughly and they're
very very well versed in a subject
but when they come to a conversation
they're not interested in understanding
the subject or coming to Solutions on
problems they're interested in something
else and I think that's a big I think
that's actually a very large
undergirding issue with the way that we
address things in society
I'm not super worried about leftist
YouTubers typically honest when we're
talking about what's going on with Gen
Saki and the federal government I I
understand that when it came to the 2020
election they played a huge role in
helping the fascistic establishment
machine take power and that sucks
but that's happened we have the audits
happening we'll see if what more comes
from that we'll see where we end up but
regardless of any of it it seems like
we're heading towards some kind of
breakup
peaceful divorce yeah decentralization
at the very least
though Federal government's become too
powerful and now it's starting to lose a
lot of that power like one of the things
we mentioned the other day and we
mentioned quite often the Democrats use
the federal government to enact local
laws
for everybody in areas that aren't local
to them and I think a lot of people do
this too when it's funny when you see
someone running for congress and they'll
be like if you vote for me I'll make you
know I'll make this place better it's
like I'm from Saint Paul Minneapolis and
I want to make Saint Paul clean so vote
for me and it's like bro you represent
us to the feds you go you go to you go
to DC you're not here to discuss budget
for the local thing about these streets
so what happens is they go to DC and
they say our streets are dirty I demand
we we create a massive federal budget to
clean up streets and then you've got
some guy who lives in the mountains of
like Wyoming and or in the Rockies and
he's like what why why are my tax
dollars going towards it that makes
literally no sense but guns are a better
example perfect somebody somebody in New
York being like these guns are a problem
we should ban them and there's a guy
fighting a grizzly bear and he hears
like you know on his radio they want to
ban guns and he's like I'm in the middle
of fighting a grizzly bear I need my gun
to fight that grizzly bear you know
there's uh water collections another
interesting one because in some some
states and I don't have a list of which
ones but it's illegal to collect
rainwater
I think because it it grows bacteria
like standing water can in mosquitoes so
you don't want it in a city they in some
areas of Rural America you you need you
know it's because it's just terrain it's
because of groundwater so the pla
typically the places that ban water
collection is because it would
eventually deplete groundwater reserves
so the water has to cycle into the soil
and everything like that way in Colorado
it's it's not about one person having
water it's about if everyone was doing
it but then there's some places that
don't do it imagine if some guy you know
like imagine if Arizona went to the
federal government and said we want to
pass a bill that says the Great Lakes
should share their water with everybody
well not everybody needs the Great Lakes
water and the Great Lakes needs it more
than you do but they need water so they
want to pass laws that affect everybody
so my so now that we're we're past 2020
I I what am I supposed to do am I
supposed to go to a lot of these like
left YouTuber types who are like please
vote for Joe Biden and be like here's a
big list of everything you screwed up I
think a lot of people realize how bad
things are how they got duped the
promises that were made with the
Democrats didn't come true and now you
have all these you know Biden voters
posting their elves on Twitter and now
I'm just like okay I'm honestly not
worried about the useful idiots I got
burned by George Bush when he told us
their weapons of mass destruction I
think everyone needs to get burned once
by a politician by President and to
realize that that system is susceptible
to corruption it's tough dude because
you know what it is it's that we trust
and so when you're young and you you
you're you know in your 20s and then
Obama comes around and he's like I'm
gonna bring change and Hope get our
troops out of the Middle East it's going
to be great and then you're like this
fantastic and the war on drugs and
you're like wow this is it this is what
I've been waiting for I grew up with
these bad guys here's a good guy and
then you get burned and you're like wow
he was a bad guy screw everybody young
people they give the benefit of the
doubt they don't do it again sometimes
people do but I think most of the
establishment people on social media
man they are absolutely just
looking for some kind of personal gain
from the win what do you mean
establishment people like the the media
people the overstate the cathedral
they're absolutely going to lie cheat
and steal because they're going to be
empowered you know you said it you said
it a couple times earlier this week and
I think you made the point very clear uh
when Joe Biden is talking he's not
talking to you that's what he's mean
he's talking to his Elites you say yeah
we're doing these things for our own
good your opinion on the matter is
irrelevant you you as a person Ian like
or my I you know one
when you when you present the world in
that kind of way he's not interested in
what you think
and so when you even look at
balkanization and decentralization
they're the same thing but one of them
balkanization is more of a a Breaking of
political structures as opposed to uh
decentralization starts in the home
how so uh so you you know like you have
you have your experience where you get
burned by a politician you might become
cynical if nothing else or at least
suspicious of all all of your political
of anything political but that itself is
not self-sufficiency that itself is just
skepticism and skepticism does not
skepticism manifests into nihilism and
then you just go crazy so we don't want
that so it would you get this
balkanization this structure that we're
talking about is when I'm voting for
somebody for the House of
Representatives I know that they're
going to the House of Representatives of
Representatives of the feds so I'm
interested in their representative
representation of my state to the
federal government I'm not interested in
their representation to my state to its
own people because I am sending them as
a representative to the federal
government and so I focus a lot more on
local politics right if I live in
Brooklyn Center I am interested in who
is the city Council of Brooklyn Center
if you look at a lot of The Strife
that's gone through Minneapolis in the
last year it's all on the local level
and then people on the federal level
like Maxine Waters come in and cause
more but they don't create it themselves
they add on to the chaos of the city so
when you look at like decentralization
you could say why is it that or here's
two really good examples referring to
guns Joe Biden's uh not Joe Biden
himself but like the ATF currently put
out new letters redefining theoretically
redefining what abrasives making these
guns sbrs and it's a whole big legal
problem it effectively will make
anywhere between 10 and 30 million
people felons overnight so yeah if you
know if you if you uh
with confiscation it's also kind of
trouble right so
you have that issue and then Texas goes
we as a state will not allow the federal
government to enforce this law they are
decentralizing their understanding of
firearms rights from the federal
government they're not getting it from
the top down California did the same
thing you're not allowed to own these
guns in our city or in our state
two very good examples of the opposite
ends of the scale of both people being
decentralized the states ultimately
compromise the United States so what'd
you say SB something SB tactical no you
said um they were trying to make stocks
illegal to make it an SB SBR
short-bailed rifle I apologize thank you
yeah if you wanna if you want to look
into like the history of terrible laws
look at the NFA um oh yeah the National
Firearms Act because if your Barrel is
too short now you're a bad person yep
why is that because it's easier to
conceal there's there's a functionally
in our current life that where we live
now it is completely arbitrary and it's
because of the the bureaucratic bloat
laws never go away they always get
attitude there's there's a forward grip
I don't know it's called but it's like
slight angle and I was told that if you
hold it improperly it turns your your
pistol into a rifle
if you put a four the ATF has determined
that if you put a four grip a vertical
foregrip on the front of your on on a
large frame pistol that has a brace it
is considered turning it into an SBR but
there's there's a one grip that's
actually it's like a it's like a wedge
right yeah I'm talking about yeah the
Magpul angled foregrip I was told that
if you hold it the way it's supposed to
beholded you're fine but then if you
hold it like oh you're supposed to have
your hand in front of it but are behind
it and if you put your hand on it it
makes it a foregrip and now it's
yeah I I do not know the answer to that
one because that is another really
really good point on why this whole NFA
National Firearms Act is so problematic
is because one it was it was a a gun
confiscation scheme that started a long
time ago that failed it basically failed
in the senate or in the legislation
um and then
so that it was just again we're gonna
make we want to take all the guns away
okay no let's compromise okay we'll only
make these illegal that's one problem
and then after that well Firearms
technology has changed massively since
that 3D printing it can't keep up with
it the the legislation cannot keep up
with it and the change in how Firearms
are used and how people are used doing
uh they're shooting different types of
competitions they're looking for
different types of firearms for home
defense they're not just it's not all
your granddad's bolt action anymore are
they gonna are they gonna make um um
rail guns
they have them they're they already
exist they're just not very I mean like
NFA items are they going to make
railguns banned are they gonna
you know let's not give the enemy
thanks for checking out this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time